we cannot afford to make mistakes
that lead to the loss of life
of other people in in our profession
and so i do fully support
releasing the officer of her duties
that was a fox news alert this afternoon
the mayor of brooklyn center made
his position clear he wants to fire the
female officer who
accidentally shot and killed a young
black man over the weekend
but the city manager kurt bogany
disagreed
he advocated for an investigation and
due process
watch and in response to the question
about termination
all employees working for the city of
brooklyn center
are entitled to due process with respect
to discipline
this employee will receive due process
due process discipline will be
determined
if i were to say anything else i would
actually be
contradicting the idea of due process
they do realize due process is part of
the law
and for demanding due process it appears
kurt
bogany has just been fired the mayor
announcing a short time ago
quote effective immediately our city
manager has been relieved of his duties
i will continue to work my hardest to
ensure good leadership
at all levels of our city government
mike tobin is on the ground and brooklyn
center minnesota with the latest
mike uh we just got this breaking news
what are you hearing from your sources
well there's also a word out of the
mayor's office that the city council
gave them the power to assume command
and control over the police department
so the uh
the mayor out here of course uh mike
kelly very upset at what happened you
heard him say very clearly that he
thinks that this officer needs to be
fired
and the police chief among those is
another one who said that
you need to have some due process as far
as what is happening out here on the
ground you have people who are very
angry
you hear the noise that they're making
right now the curfew curfew's about to
go into effect in a less than 10 minutes
and walking around what surprised me
here lawrence is walking around and
talking to people in this crowd
everyone that i spoke with says they're
not intent on defying the curfew
the numbers are out here right now
they're making their voices heard but as
this curfew goes into effect it'll go
into effect
here for hennepin county and all the
counties surrounding minneapolis
uh the people here anyway with whom i
spoke say they intend to respect it
uh you do know that you have the
manpower that is in effect uh because of
operation safety net
and you saw the leaders out here make
mistakes last time around they didn't
stand up to
the curfew and the protesters who came
out uh last time and you saw the
disaster that ultimately unfolded
following the death of george floyd
but if you look at the people out here
right now i can tell you the numbers in
the last 10 15 minutes have dwindled to
some extent
you see the fortifications outside of
the police headquarters
and you see the numbers of police the
bright yellow those are the state
troopers
and you have a number of agencies who
are out here uh in front
of the of the police headquarters in
brooklyn center
that's our scene right now the people
say they
largely will obey the curfew but they're
out here right now making their voices
heard and we'll see if we get any kind
of a repeat
of what we saw last night lawrence so
mike i got to ask you this
what are they calling for on the ground
do they want the officer arrested
because the process is being taken
there's investigation taking place
it seems like the city has already said
that
they want to move on they're just
waiting for the process to take place
so what do the people on the ground want
well unfortunately i've been to so many
of these and what you get with the
people on the ground
is immense immediately they want a
conviction and they want a sentence
they talk about justice but they want to
rush right to
a conclusion and get justice based on
the conclusion they have arrived at with
a preliminary set of facts
speaking of the facts that are coming in
we also have word from the hennepin
county medical examiner this evening
that they have determined the cause of
death in this case and they're calling
it a homicide
now you can't be alarmist when you hear
them say homicide because in this
in this context homicide simply means a
death that was unnatural death that was
caused by someone else
so real quickly and that's interesting
details you're 100 right about the
classification of the homicide
any word from the officer has she gotten
counsel
has she been is there a gag order
protective custody what do we know about
her
well the earpiece broke up a little bit
but i think you're asking
about the mother of mr right in this
case
and we know that ben crump has now
signed on with that family ben crump
who's become very prominent in a lot of
these cases
across the nation uh very well known in
fact for the george floyd case but they
because they were able to arrive at this
record 27 million dollar settlement with
the city
so ben crump very active here in
minneapolis he is now
uh representing uh the wright family
lawrence
thank you mike uh and that's five
minutes until they have to be out there
uh so we'll be covering it and tucker
will be as well after this
important note ben crump been involved
he is a civil rights attorney that means
that they are
already moving to build a case to sue
them
in civil court not the criminal process
so that is two different
processes taking place at one time